first of all congrats on the movie I
said that before but let me say it again
um one of the things I think over the
last few years people have gotten very
comfortable of watching things at home
and I want to emphasize that this is a
movie you want to see in a movie theater
so can you sort of talk about that
aspect of the film that you you want to
get off your ass and go see this oh yeah
absolutely and we're not it's not even
the action that that obviously would
draw you into a theater to feel like you
can actually feel at the gunshots it's I
I think it's also the way it was shot
Eric Messerschmitt and his credits alone
showcase that you want to see his work
and JD's work on a big screen yeah and
movies are back and we have like the
best aerial photography team yeah the
history of filmmaking like when that's
not that's not hyperbole like it is you
want to give these guys the do that
their work is worthy of by seeing this
thing on the big screen see it in IMAX
you will literally experience the film
in a different way I mean it this this
is what movie making is all about this
is why you go see something on the big
screen not only that but it's an
opportunity to get back together in
community with this beautiful story
about Community about you know about
finding common ground and like there's
something really beautiful and and
important about getting together in like
a dark movie theater with a bunch of
strangers and watching something
powerful like that that I think really
brings us together no better time to do
it in Thanksgiving too Joe I am curious
is there any similarity in preparing for
a movie and for a tour because from the
outside it feels like there's a lot of
mental preparation physical preparation
and I'm just curious if there's any
similarity uh it's a great question
um maybe for some not for not for myself
I felt like uh this project
is
is so heavy on so many levels and you're
on the Move constantly on tour even in
rehearsals it's like a couple days in
and out you know you just get I think
that feels like something that
personally I when I go on go on the road
I'm like I know what to expect with Pro
when you're immersing yourself in a new
role or new project like I I want to be
on the ground and spend time getting to
know the character but you're you're not
on a plane you're not going to the next
place to tap to do that and
um I think this was was nice to put your
feet up somewhere for three four months
and say okay like this is home and I
want to just immerse myself in as much
Marty good and these the fighting 32s as
I can
um and I I think it's yeah nice to
separate the two in some way for both of
you what is this what is the secret to
making sure that you are portraying uh a
real person in the most honest and
authentic way that you can and uh you
know prior to stepping on set humility I
think it it it's there's uh there's no
greater Preparatory starting place than
understanding that uh another human life
and another human stories worth uh in in
terms of being told accurately and being
portrayed accurately is is incredibly
important regardless of what your
personal opinion is about the person
that you're playing
um it's it's humility you come in
recognizing that this life mattered or
else we wouldn't be telling a story
about it and uh doing all the rest of
the work that you have to do in order to
occupy that space for you know whether
it's it's the heroes that we got to
portray or if it's Jeffrey Dahmer you
know that it is there's a degree of
humility that you have to approach all
of that stuff with there's an importance
to also finding your own
um
Rhythm within the person that you're
portraying how how much you call the
Family how many emails do you get
because at some point
for myself I just had to pump the brakes
and say okay I got enough information
and and
um I don't need to obsess over this I
think it's it's also part of what we do
and why we love to do what we do is that
we get to kind of
sprinkle our own little magic on it or
[ __ ] on it whatever you want to be able
to do
um to do uh what we love the most on
that note I need to stop I'm just going
to say again congrats I really hope it's
a huge hit for you guys thank you so
much